it is a bleak picture this year alone
has seen storms
floods and wildfires
now according to scientists it is
unequivocal the humans are largely to
blame
for warming the oceans land and
atmosphere through our burning of coal
oil and gas you've been telling us for
over three decades of the dangers of
allowing the planets
warm the world listened but didn't hear
the world listen but it did not act
strongly enough
and as a result climate change is a
problem
that is here now nobody is safe
and it's getting worse faster and that
has been repeatedly demonstrated by
the reporting that we've been doing here
in turkey and in greece on the
devastating wildfires that have swept
across
southern europe now these wildfires do
happen every year but it is the scale of
them
and the intensity of them that has taken
everybody by surprise
this year and that looks set to continue
the first un report issued in 1990 had
predicted human cause climate change
would become evident
at the time it couldn't prove with
evidence that it was happening
that's now changed on nearly every
measurement
our climate is more extreme and it's set
to get worse human activities are
causing climate change
and making extreme weather events more
frequent
and severe second it shows that
climate change is affecting every region
on our planet
and lastly it explains that strong rapid
sustained
reductions in carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gas emissions
would be required to limit global
warming
right now it's some of the world's
poorest countries that are feeling the
effects
but they contribute less to greenhouse
gases
there is hope though if the biggest
emitters are able to commit to
and deliver sharp reductions in
greenhouse gas emissions
we may see some positive changes
but it would have to happen within the
next 20 years
the covered 19 pandemic briefly reduced
air pollution
but it did not halt climate change the
damage it seems
already done some issues like
greenland's glaciers melting
and sea levels rising are irreversible
and unless there's a dramatic change in
human behavior
the world should expect an unsettled and
uncertain future
nick lark al jazeera southern turkey